all right let's get started um
yeah so we're very happy to have uh ryan
tell us about uh optimizing non-commuted
polynomials and hopefully something a
little bit about black holes so that was
all your black holes sorry
uh great thanks so uh
let's talk about this problem
uh maximize
pravesh talked about even the first
lecture here some over like
j1 less than j2 less than j3 less than
j4
they're between 1 and n
of some real coefficient a s let me just
say s stands for
j1 through j4
times like some indeterminate chi j1
ij2
ij3
ij4
uh okay and
like in professions talk you know we'll
say subject to
chi j squared equals one for all j
okay so you would think of this as like
optimizing a homogeneous degree four
polynomial over the boolean cube which
is something i know like a lot of you
have thought about before
uh now actually when you
do this when you you know try to solve
it or like throw your sum of squares
algorithm at it or whatnot
you actually have like another uh
relation in mind besides just this one
xj squared equals one
you're actually always thinking to
yourself this too chi j chi k
equals
chi k chi j
for all j not equal to k
okay because well you know
multiplication of two numbers commutes
so that's good
uh
okay so uh
in some sense this what this talk is
gonna be about is like
what if instead of all the
um indeterminate commuting like what if
they were to
anti-commute
um
[Music]
that's my last audio joke
um
of course
uh you might say like what does it even
mean like what are we doing here like
numbers commute so what what are these
pi j is supposed to stand for well
actually they should stand for the
things that they uh you know they um
you might normally think of as a
representation they should stand for
matrices okay and matrices have the
potential to commute so what we're
really looking for here is like a
representation
this is like over
you know representations like pi or you
can just think of it as like assignments
that map all the chi j's
to matrices
in some dimension okay and
any dimension d of your choice
uh
and you know sorry to introduce complex
numbers but i guess in you know
representations it's like actually more
pleasant to allow complex matrices so
we're gonna do that
uh but just to like make it a little bit
more relaxing let's also add in one more
um constraint now that these matrices
are supposed to be self-adjoint or
hermitian so i'll also say that chi j
star equals chi j
for all j
right so good there's still a question
like wait what's going on what are we
trying to actually optimize here so
let's call this
h this polynomial h and i'm going to
kind of blur the distinction between
like the formal polynomial and like the
actual matrix you get under a
substitution so this thing is a matrix
what are we trying to optimize we're
trying to optimize it's like maximum
eigenvalue okay so really the
maximization is
maximize the
eigenvalue of this
okay or if you're like a physics person
we're looking for the ground state
energy of minus h i mean sorry to
physics people but it's too stressful
for me to have the optimum being
negative so we're going to try to
maximize
uh
great so um
one more thing uh now that these uh
matrices could potentially be complex or
even before that
you might think oh they could have like
complex eigenvalues maybe that's a
little stressful but we're only ever
going to consider um polynomials which
are
themselves self-adjoint
and therefore have real eigenvalues and
therefore you know this maximization is
just maximizing over real eigenvalues so
just to
clarify some things these are going to
be in this talk real numbers
and i claim this h will actually always
be self-adjoint under any substitution
so let's just check that
um for fun so h star
is going to be the sum over all these
ordered sets of j's
of
you know a s chi j one through chi j
four
star
which is okay the a's are real so that's
fine
and the kai jays are self-adjoint so
this only has the effect of reversing
them
i j one
actually let me write it all the way out
pi j three chi j two this is sort of
just for practice chi j1
so now we can use the anti-commutation
property as much as we like and let's do
that to like reorder them so
i'll draw some funny arrows and
hopefully you'll see what i mean like
we're going to use anti-commutation to
bring this chi j4 here that gives a
minus sign and then here and then here
that's three minus signs and we push the
chi j4 to the end
and then we'll get another one here and
another one here that's two more and now
j3 got pushed the end and we'll do like
one more to push k2 into this right
place and we picked up like six minus
signs
which is nothing
okay and so we end up with this
which is uh h does this depend on having
an 8th degree polynomial or something
like this yes it did depend on having an
even degree polynomial uh so in the work
we consider other degree polynomials but
we're going to stick to degree 4 in this
in this talk
great
okay so you may have several questions
at this point and if you ever have any
questions feel free to just ask them
um
two things you could ask uh first of all
why would you consider this it's a valid
question and i'll try to say some things
about that
and another thing that you could ask
which i'll address first is
well are you maximizing over an empty
set
do there even exist like matrices that
all pairwise commute like this
and uh the answer is yes
and in some sense there's kind of like a
unique choice i'll sort of say what i
mean by that
so here's a fact
um
there exists
like a representation or assignment
whatever you want to call it
um
pi
that maps these kjs
into a d dimensional matrices
where d
is
two to the n over two okay in fact you
can't do it in less dimension okay so
such matrices and mutually
anti-commuting matrices that square to
the identity
do exist but
only in dimension that's at least
exponential i can also assume n is even
everywhere
okay
and
uh
in some sense which i don't want to like
bother like spending time uh trying to
make precise they're kind of like
unique
irreducible
such representation
so up to
conjugating this specific assignment pi
by unitaries which doesn't change any of
the relations or the maximum eigenvalue
and up to like taking several such
representations and then stacking them
block diagonally which also doesn't
improve your ability to optimize this
there's actually sort of just like one
representation
and i'll tell it to you
briefly
it maps like a
chi j to a matrix called gamma j
the physicists call these like majorana
operators or majorana gamma matrices
and i can tell you what it is like so
gamma one
is like the pali x
operator uh times i
times i times et cetera as i'm writing
this let me stress that it's 100 not
important to know this specific thing
we're actually only going to use these
relations to do our own all our analysis
but i thought i'd tell it to you anyway
so like
a bunch of i's this is like n over two
factors
um gamma three is like z x i's
gamma four is like z y i's
this is only if you care the next one's
like z z x z z y
okay and if you like while i'm talking
if you know these matrices you can
verify to yourself that they all
pairwise and commute
so these are all two matrices yeah x y
and z are these certain two by two poly
matrices this is like um
yeah zero one one zero is x and but the
only thing you need to know about those
is these are three little two by two
matrices that pairwise
um well i'd like x times y is z and so
forth like the quaternions
[Music]
yeah i think if you can yeah i think you
can represent them in n dimensions with
uh completely real matrices
and uh we're not going to get stressed
too much about that either so you can
you can think about that too
um
okay so actually because of this sort of
uniqueness like without loss of
generality you can basically assume it's
this assignment
actually i guess that's how like
physicists think about it they don't
think about it sort of in the way i
described where like you're searching
over all possible assignments to try to
optimize this they literally just think
of this one fixed assignment i have in
mind
but still the problem is not trivial
because this is like an exponential size
um
these are exponential size matrices and
so this is like also
an exponential size matrix that's sort
of implicitly told to you like you're
told it's like this polynomial these are
numbers that are given to you in the
input you know it's these matrices so
you're trying to find this largest
eigenvalue of this implicitly
represented
huge matrix
actually there is one nice thing to know
about these
matrices which is that they're all
sparse
they're all
exactly as sparse
as uh the identity matrix
so the number of non-zeros is um d
okay
and so you're actually adding up you
know n to the fourth such products of
sparse matrices so the overall matrix is
sparse it has like poly log and
dimension number of entries
so it's this implicitly represented
exponentially large sparse matrix you're
trying to understand its largest
eigenvalue
like
you don't
there's still mullis multiple
assignments right because you could just
you could permute because the asses are
different for different sets right so i
could like pick which ji goes to which
gamma
uh
yeah so i guess the point is that like
um
this is an assignment a different
assignment would like involve as you say
shuffling these around but it would have
the same largest eigenvalue
why is that given that the as's are
different for different
yeah i guess it's not obvious but it's
uh no matter what is i give you a
different assignment we'll have the
yeah i think
you can shuffle it i believe this is
right i might be wrong but like i think
if you like shuffled these then there'd
be like a one unitary which
i think would be equivalent to like
conjugating all of these by fixed
unitary would achieve that shuffling and
therefore they would be equivalent to
conjugating h by a fixed unitary
even that's okay because like the eu's
would come here and they would cancel on
the insides
yep
got a good question yep
it has to be a permutation of that
collection of yeah so any polynomial you
write down
first of all uh
by using the anti-commutation relations
as much as possible you can like move
the m determinants around in the
ordering in each monomial at the expense
of changing the signs
and then if ever two adjacent ones
collide like you can use the fact that
the square is one to erase it so you can
take any
polynomial make it multilinear and even
make it so that in the monomials it's
always in lexicographic order
up to changing the signs
so it sounds like this is like the most
general degree four polynomial you can
write down since you have these
religions okay but like so from the
anti-commuting relations
it seems like like i can't set you know
pi one and pi two both to equal gamma
one right correct
yeah
yeah
you have to
yeah it's not so easy to find matrices
that's out of that all mutually
it makes using a much smaller dimension
um
i think it's elementary
but not like super easy like i don't
think you would prove it to yourself in
like 10 minutes
but
you could read like a short like eight
six page explanation that's totally
elementary
okay so i mean
presumably showing this is going to boil
down to showing that like the algebra of
c adjoined
all of these operators modulo their
um relations is equivalent to some
matrix algebra and d dimensions exactly
right these are actually this uh the
matrix algebra with this well the matrix
algebra c d times d is isomorphic to
this matrix algebra of non-computed upon
nails with these relations
um that's like like an elementary fact
and i guess representation theory of
algebras but i
mean uh okay
so that's uh one question the other
question was like why why would you care
to do this i mean it seemed fun but uh
yeah why so uh
one reason is
um it turns out that this is actually
the
arguably like the most fundamental
problem in quantum chemistry
it's like literally this
so like
arguably the like most basic problem
in quantum chemistry
and it's sometimes called um
electronic structure or electron
structure
i don't know about actual science so
i was gonna say please don't ask me any
questions but you can ask me these
questions but i might just say i don't
know
um yeah
can you briefly explain why
oh great okay good question so yeah let
me say some words like that and then
i'll say some words about that too
so uh
what is what is this like maybe you
imagine you have a molecule and it has
some electrons and there's some
interactions between the
um uh electrons and like you have like
maybe all possible pairwise interactions
are possible
and uh each one has like a
coupling which is like some sort of
strength and that gives you hamiltonian
and you're interested in the ground
state of that hamiltonian because
that'll tell you how the electrons will
be structured
that's the extent of what i know about
that now you might say like
there's something kind of funny here
because
okay you have like all pairwise
interactions you might guess that that
uh would lead to a degree two polynomial
wouldn't that make sense
apparently not i mean i guess not i
guess the reason is like for like
fermions like electrons
you know if you have a fermion it always
has like a creation operator and an
annihilation operator
and so like if you have two fermions
interacting there's like four matrices
like the creation and annihilation
operator for one the creation and
annihilation operator for the other so
that's why this is degree four
and anybody that knows more about that
feel free to say
yeah you have a question terry sorry
like uh how is how are degree treatments
without a disclosure
good so you can put in degree two terms
if you want if you do then it's most
pleasant to like put in i times like a
real coefficient
times chi j chi k
because this will be self-adjoint like
if you star this without the i then
you'll get ki j and that's the negative
of that
so it's you could be like okay fine my
spectrum is purely
imaginary in that case but it's nicer to
just stick in an eye on the degree two
terms to keep itself a joint
uh i'll say something else about your
question maybe it's not answering your
question but i shall say it um
yeah so uh
in fact because of what i said that this
like sort of models like pairwise
interactions with you know fermions
it turns out that like as an algorithmic
problem this problem right here with
degree 4
has the flavor of being like more
difficult than the degree two
commutative case which is kind of like
you know max cut charrington kirkpatrick
etc
but less difficult than like the degree
four commuting case which we kind of
know is like very hard and hard to
approximate and so forth
and maybe even closer to the degree 2k
so it's like somebody with a weird sweet
spot where this might be like actually
kind of tractable and have some
interesting algorithms and things
um and to further say some more things
about your question chris uh
the homogeneous degree two version of
this problem is easy
it's not obvious but there's like a
classical algorithm that's efficient
that um
kind of like diagonalizes the degree two
thing and just tells you the exact
optimum
it's three five minutes
okay so you diagonalize a and then
um
yeah like up to like a unitary
transformation you can like make all the
monomials have disjoint indices in the
degree two case and then it kind of acts
like the commutative case
um
okay so sort of in the for worst case
instances it's kind of like quantum
chemists like really like this problem
um
there's also the
average case instances the gaussians
okay so this is called the syk model so
it's like you take the sk model and you
put a y in the middle
it's like satchev via and kitev
this is the random case
uh so the a s's are independent
gaussians
and let's agree to make their variance
one over n choose four
or to put a square root 1 over n choose
4 here just so that for normalization
um so that
i always like to have this sum over s a
s squared equals 1 well in expectation
in this case
so if your business loves the syk model
they use a different normalization than
this and i'm probably annoying you but i
think for this crowd and for me i like
it
um
so this average case version of the
problem was like studied in the 1970s by
nuclear physicists and then in like the
80s by condensed matter physicists but
somehow physics people got really
excited like string theorists got really
excited
in the maybe 90s when kittayev you know
the quantum computation person among
other things like
proposed this as like a tractable model
for
black holes
um
so somehow in a way that i really don't
understand this is like an excellent
model for um
the zero dimensional boundary of
one-dimensional black holes and like
there's holography
and maximally chaotic
stuff and other terms that i don't
really understand but it's kind of
exciting that like whenever you type
like syk model into like google you get
all these papers about like black holes
and holography and string theory and
it's really exciting um so they really
love this model but i also love it too
because yeah it's a random degree four
polynomial like that's no problem it's
cool it's great
um so it's hard for me to explain much
more about why they're super interested
in it but let me tell you one thing
that's empirically true about this syk
model the random model which is our main
interest in this work although we also
say some things about the worst case
instances
um that i think is connected to why
they're very excited about this model
so it's a model of
a random you know you're looking at the
eigenvalues of random kind of sparse
matrix
and but it's got an eigenvalue
distribution that's not
the kind they expected at first maybe
so um
empirically and according to like
physics heuristics
so seemingly
um
uh the eigenvalue
distribution
of
h by which i mean the 2 to the n over 2
dimensional matrix you get by these are
random and then these are that fixed
assignment
uh looks like
a gaussian actually
um
or perhaps a truncated gaussian they're
not exactly sure
um
and so this is like you know supposed to
be like a histogram of the eigenvalues
of h so it's actually some discretized
thing
and um
you know there are two to the n over two
eigenvalues because that's the dimension
so you might think that this like
maximum is kind of like
you know the maximum value if you drew
two to the n over two gaussians
which would be like square root of log
of two to the n over two
so it'd be like theta of like
proportional to root n
and
this uh oops this is like the physics
belief or knowledge about what is the
answer with high probability it's
proportional to root n
um and they even have some heuristics
which i'll talk a tiny bit about if i
get a chance that says it's
even like n over i think um two root
sorry root n over two root two okay so
they feel like they know the constant
um but one thing that i guess is
surprising to them which makes them
gives them some joy is it's kind of um
different that um there are
exponentially few states that are like
achieving close to the maximum
and this is somehow like different from
like
a sort of typical thing that happens
when you have some kind of random matrix
model and maybe you expect like a
circular semi-circular law
where
there's some like really hard boundary
here and like a constant fraction of the
states are like pretty high
like no it seems that like it's it's
different like there are only
exponentially few states that are close
to optimum
so uh that's that
any yeah
yeah
uh
i don't know but uh shortly i will tell
you another elementary argument
that will show that the answer is big o
of rooting
um
yeah so it's a classical situation where
like you read the physics papers they're
like really into like exactly nailing
the asymptotic spacing right around here
and they like looking at the expansions
the distributions whereas like the math
papers are like let's try to prove it's
bigger over
again um yeah
any more questions
okay let me tell you some of the results
uh in our paper maybe the two main
results in our paper
um
and in some sense they're both of like
the form
um mathematically
proving that it's theta of root n
although there's algorithmic aspects to
both our results
okay so theorem one
uh
with high probability this is all for
syk model with high probability um
degree 6
sos
certifies
that uh opt
of h is at most some constant c one
times root n okay and in our proof
c1 is
some number
one plus root six square root which is
like 1.86 or something
okay so there's an efficient algorithm
that certifies with high probability but
probably every instance certifies the
truth is big o of root n and the
constant is not too bad even
this is like um
non-commutative sos but it's it's really
the same as le if you know sos that you
love like you there are no surprises in
what's going on with this sos
uh formulation of the problem
so in fact what this means i mean
literally what this means is
uh the algorithm
like shows that c1 root n minus h
is representable like in the algebra as
a sum of
squares
uh like g j
star g j
okay and that is a certificate if you
can find uh an identity like this in the
algebra because even under any
substitution the right hand side will be
psd and therefore
that certifies that h has all the
eigenvalues at most this
okay
and also interestingly as an aside
we can also show that degree 4 sos
doesn't work
so remark you can show that degree 4 sos
sort of the minimum
uh thinks
that ops could be
at least root uh n
um
great
uh
in the meantime let me tell you another
uh fact from the literature this is like
the mathematics mathematicians
literature
it's like um renji fong dong tian and
dong chi liu
they showed not too long ago
this fact so previously
it was shown by kind of a simple
argument although it's a very clever
argument with high probability uh the
optimum
is at most uh
c2 times root n where c2 is a smaller
constant it's um root lon two
okay which is i don't know point eight
three
and this argument of theirs is similar
in flavor if you know to like the the
churn off bound that shows if you choose
like a random csp or whatever with high
probability the optimum will be small
so in particular it has that like
unsosable flavor like you prove that you
know in advance of choosing a random
instance with high probability it's
going to have a really small
optimum or this small optimum but like
once you're faced with the actual
instance you're like please certify to
me that this instance has a small
optimum
this proof doesn't help you do it
but we showed that you you can't do it
efficiently
you haven't said that gap is real or
uh
it's too early to tell there are a lot
of open problems uh yeah i mean this was
the best thing we could get and it
seemed like maybe if you tinker with it
you could improve this but yeah don't
know
uh
okay and as i said though the physics
heuristic is that the optimum is like
this even smaller constant i don't know
it's like point three
something five or nine
but from the problems that we all know
and love the gap is between two and four
yeah that's funny
i don't
i don't know
the best thing i could say is that like
in some weird mystical sense it's like
most resembles degree two in the
commutative case
and then maybe you can imagine there are
some instances where like degree two sos
doesn't know the answer but if you allow
something like triangle inequality
you can do it
so that's the spirit in which i imagine
something like this is plausible
yeah
so is the constant in front of the
square
that is strictly
correct
correct so
it's not uh it's like a slightly more
sophisticated i just think a little lip
here there is an underlying heuristic
that says uh this should look like a
gaussian but for some reasons it's like
a different consonant here than you
would get if there's literally just a
gaussian
very sharp andrea he's good
yeah okay uh
so theorem two
theorem two
that we prove
is
um
the lower bound theorem two with high
probability
um the optimum
is at least uh let's just say omega root
n we don't have an explicit constant
here
and in fact
well i'll fill in this in fact in a
moment
but okay this is the lower bound
um
one thing i can say is uh to our
knowledge there was not previously any
explicit lower bound proven even though
the physicists you know like know what
it is um
it wasn't proven
sorry
um
[Music]
yeah actually in this work of uh this is
uh
fung tian and
um where is it
uh
it's implicit in this work you can get
from this work that uh with high
probability the optimum
is um little omega of one it goes to
infinity with n
you can get that out of their work with
no trouble but um we show what i guess
is the right lower bound
and
um the in fact is like related to
algorithmic certification of this lower
bound
so
you're used to the fact that the the
sense in these these problems like this
that like okay on the upper bound you
need to talk about like certification
and so forth but for the lower bound
like you normally just like i exhibit
the
assignment of plus and minus once these
x's and that's obviously a certificate
but in this version it's actually not
clear how to certify lower bounds
efficiently either like what you're
gonna do like you know even what like um
uh
gammas like matrices you're supposed to
plug in here but they're an exponential
dimension so how do you certify that
this uh implicitly described
exponentially large matrix has a large
eigenvalue you could try to say what the
large eigenvector is but that's an
exponential size object so it's kind of
unclear
um
although i should mention that in the
degree 2 case you sort of face the same
difficulties but you can do it
i mean you can implicitly describe the
optimal eigenvector and like in
polynomial time
and
it constitutes a certificate that the
thing is large
um
so
the in fact is as follows it's
like a quantum certification algorithm
for this
let me say what i mean
uh there exists an efficient
you know polytime
quantum algorithm w
that outputs
a quantum
state basically kind of like the the
large eigenvector that's certifying this
so it's outputting like a log
d which is like n over two qubit state
um rho
it's like the output you give it h you
give it the coefficients of h it outputs
this quantum state rho is like n over
two qubits
such that
um
when
h is chosen from syk
or h chosen from syk meaning all the
coefficients are gaussians
um at random
with high probability
um trace
rho
h is at least omega root n
okay so like
this is like a
an eigenvector which is like asserting
that
uh there's an eigenvalue of h that's at
least root n
put a question
in what sense is that about putting this
statement
good so let me talk about that the
question was in what sense is like
outputting the state so um this is a
quantum computer like and therefore it
can output like n over two qubits whose
state is this row
but you still have some questions
because
how is this like a certificate like how
do you
check this fact
um
the thing is
uh
if you have a quantum computer
this task is checking this is doable
efficiently
albeit
randomly so this is actually kind of a
very subtle point about what it means to
certify something so like
allow me to ask you to think about this
like subtle point um
so
uh here's a remark
given
any
h
and
any quantum
state quantum state
row
um
there exists like a very simple i mean
if you know quantum it's it's it's easy
simple algorithm
quantum algorithm
or empirically estimating trace rho h
up to like small air so in particular
like
uh for any accuracy like plus or minus
one over a poly n which is
more than enough accuracy since you're
just trying to certify this
and like confidence
1 minus delta so it's kind of still like
a randomized algorithm
you get confidence 1 minus delta and
this is in time poly n quantum time
poly n and log one over delta
and this holds for any row in any age
it's just a simple like estimation
empirical estimation algorithm to
empirically estimate this fact
so what i'm trying to say is if you have
a quantum computer this is like a good
certification algorithm that you should
be happy about
because
it doesn't depend on the input there's
like this tunable confidence parameter
that you can make whatever you want no
matter what the input is you can set it
to be 2 to the minus 500 and an extra
factor of 500
and like really become genuinely certain
okay up to probability to the minus 500
that
this row
uh is uh good it's like a good state
that certifies that it's root n
yeah
this is the algorithm the constant is
only over like the randomness of the
algorithm so it works for any age any
quantum state not to do with that so
you're like you're not cheating by like
saying like oh if i get a good draw from
syk i can certify it
literally for any output you can
basically
test this
with a quantum computer with like zero
error
uh yes
classical certificate
good
uh let me come back to that in a moment
uh
to say that um
we don't know any classical algorithm
with the same property we meaning like
me and matt uh don't
know
any
classical uh efficient
certification algorithm
[Music]
for
you know ops
of h
at least
omega
root n
you know with high probability over
h drawn from s y k
whereas i you know say to you that we do
know an efficient quantum algorithm for
this task certifying that a random syk
instance has
value at least root n
and so arguably we have here an example
of a natural problem where there's an
efficient quantum algorithm and we don't
know an efficient classical algorithm
which is kind of cool
uh
yeah
so
to your question siddhant
um
[Music]
yeah it's hard to say what a classical
algorithm could look like one one thing
that um
could be is a classical algorithm can
output
a classical description of a quantum
state
and not just that should work but
this classical description should have
the property
that given the description and given any
polynomial h
you can efficiently classically compute
or estimate
uh trace rho h
and
for example the degree two case has this
property
there's a certain class of states that
have a terrible name they're called
gaussian states they're exactly the set
of states which are optimizers for
degree two
and you can like write them down on a
piece of paper what the state is even
though it's an exponential size object
and given such a state and a polynomial
you can evaluate what is like trace of
that state times that polynomial so this
is like what a classical
um
certification algorithm might look like
it's kind of funny too because then our
algorithm that like does this like given
h
we literally write down on a piece of
paper like this state row which you know
is defined in terms of h
should work and we then we prove it
um
but uh the only like algorithm that will
like certify that for this you know that
it's not an atypical age that it's a
typical age where it works
uh that we know is a classic is a
quantum algorithm
sos
uh
yeah it's possible i don't know yeah
um i kind of feel like this is like a
fertile area where we just got started
like there's many many open questions
you can think of and like these are just
the first few things we were able to
prove
um
yeah in fact on this uh
subject yeah this is pretty good
um
if you're really picky and like
especially if you're comparing to the
kind of classical analog like the
shantae and kirkpatrick model
and you might remember like andrea's
result but so it says with high
probability there's an efficient
algorithm that finds the optimizer even
up to the correct constant
you could try that here but this also
maybe is ambitious and you might think
it's maybe not possible
so perhaps it's not possible and then
this would be like a natural
perhaps family of hamiltonians for like
a fermionic version of matt's nlts
conjecture
which i also sort of only
sort of know what it is
but like
um i guess it's like possible that and i
think physicists kind of believe this
too it's possible that like these the
optimizing states
are like really
hard to describe like they have no
efficient description
at all with high probability i guess
that's kind of what the
nlts type conjectures say
[Music]
then you have a good um so this is
really about like
true optimization exactly if you're
willing to lose a constant then there is
like a pretty okay to describe state
uh that gets that constant time to
redone
um
yeah
i could almost even stop here
um
let me just say like there's um a lot of
open problems uh there's many many open
problems you could think about
um
[Music]
like the sparse case for example of
these random polynomials um
one uh
variant on this which turned out to be
fruitful for us and we had a lot of um
results about it including like our
proof of this
relied on the variant that i'm about to
say
uh i'll just say no words so you know
the problem i told you about today it's
optimizing a degree for polynomial or
any polynomial subject to the constraint
that all the variables anti-commune
and on the other hand if you like to say
that all the variables commute then it's
exactly optimizing a polynomial over the
boolean cube which you guys know a lot
about
um
uh a generalization of both of these is
like in addition to the polynomial h i
give you a graph
and like uh the variables are associated
with the vertices and two variables
anti-commute if there's an edge and
commute if there's no edge
so for every pair of variables they
either compute or anti-commute and which
way it is is specified to you as part of
the input
um
[Music]
and
it might seem like you're just like
generalizing for generalization's sake
and it's maybe not um motivated
but um
it is motivated because i can say a
little bit of words about the physics
heuristic here
the physics heuristic like you're given
this degree four polynomial over
variables that pairwise anti-commutes
and you want to know the maximum
eigenvalue or even the eigenvalue
distribution
so you're like okay i'll do the trace
method that's what i always do i'll try
to estimate the expected value of trace
of the polynomial to k
for all the values of k and if i can do
that then i'll know the eigenvalue
distribution
but then you start to do it and you try
to expand things out and compute and
you're like this is really annoying like
it's too it's too hard um what should we
do
um
because you're multiplying these
polynomials everything empty commutes so
you make the following simplifying
assumption
like when you're
raising these polynomials to some powers
like the time comes when you like
multiply two monomials together and then
you these monomials either commute with
each other or they don't commute with
each other two monomials
um but whether they do or don't depends
on like the intersection size between
the two
sets so you just say like
whether the rather than like actually
deciding if these two monomials compute
or not i'll just
say that they compute commute with
probability p and they don't commute
with probably one minus p using like
some fresh coins
and i'll take p to be the right p such
that like
it's the actual probability that two
randomly chosen monomials of degree four
commutes
but then you just cheat and assume that
like whether two monomials commute or
not is dependent determined by like
like a random coin flip
and then you can do the calculations
it's still hard but you can do them and
then you get this picture
and
um it therefore motivates i think
studying like this more generalized
situation where you have indeterminates
that either anti-commute or commute and
that's determined in advance by some
graph
and like
um in the physics heuristic that graph
is like an error-rainy random graph
and if you were to not cheat and
actually pay attention to what the deal
is that graph would be like some
condenser-like graph
where the vertices are um sets of size
four and you put an edge if the
intersection size is even
and one thing that we prove is that for
any linear polynomial
over indeterminants that commute or
anti-commute according to a graph g
the optimum
over all linear polynomials where the
sum of squares of coefficients is one
is bounded by the lobas data function of
the graph
and that's pretty cool and that goes
into this proof
and
um it motivates like a combinatorial
problem of determining the lobos data
function of this connector-like graph
which we also do in the paper so that's
fun and there's some open questions
about that too
i'm going to stop now
but i can take your questions
yeah
does this sparse random case also have a
physics chemistry interpretation uh
i think so like i watched a youtube talk
by a physicist that was like let me tell
you about the sparse xyk model and they
studied a lot of stuff and like they
cared a lot about the sparsity
and they found some maybe unsurprising
phase transition and what things look
like when the sparsity
dips below like one times n
uh they say kind of looks like s y o k
as long as the the sparsity is bigger
than one times n the number of monoliths
and it doesn't if it's smaller
um
physics motivation i don't know there's
probably one but i don't know what it is
uh chris
so
you wrote down those majorana
operators before
and i guess generically if you multiply
four of them together
you have like a segment of c's
over here a segment of c's over here
identities in between
and then maybe x's and y's at the ends
of these segments you might have
eyes at the beginning because like they
all start with a bunch of z's so if you
multiply four of them you'll get four
copies of z and you'll get a bunch of
eyes right so it's like eyes z's eyes
eyes
okay
i was just wondering if that blended
structure
what's in your therapy too i mean i
like are you actually delving a bit into
the
combinatorics how
what these products look like
no
in fact uh a good rule of thumb that it
turned out to be was to like never try
to remember what the matrices are and
sort of only work in the like the
algebra where you just know these
relations that the
variables anti-commute
in fact the algorithm is like a bit
strange it like
well it introduces some extra
indeterminants
and like
i guess if this is called like a
variational argument you'd like
you pretend hamiltonian is something
else that's kind of like a degree two
thing and you're like i can write down
the exact optimizer for the degree two
thing and now imagine like some like
unitary rotation that takes the degree
two thing idealized thing to the real
thing and i'll try to argue that if i do
that unitary rotation to my optimal
solution for the degree 2 thing it's
still pretty good for the actual thing
and
yeah weirdly you have to like bound some
error terms which are degree 6
polynomials
and
you use this uh this theorem for it
and therefore since we don't know how to
sos it we don't like know how to get
like an sos
lower bound somehow you just know how to
prove it we need the constant from this
term somehow you need the technique from
this thing that sort of says if you have
uh
this thing basically says like if you
have uh
um
sometimes you have like a random
polynomial
uh then with high probability the
optimum is
what you would get if you just pretend
you substituted all the indeterminants
with one and just looked at the
the number that you would get but
there's some caveats but let me just say
it's like a technique you can use to try
to
prove statements like with high
probability a polynomial drawn from some
random instance has low optimum
and some random polynomials arising
this proof
for the error terms so we need this
theorem
but this algorithm has this theorem has
a property that like
it shows with high probability the
optimum is small
but like once you actually pick a
polynomial from this distribution and
it's not clear how to certify that
you said that this problem is somehow
in between degree two and degree pole so
in the worst case can we expect a
constant factor approximation
uh
yeah i don't know how to prove it but
you could yeah in that case you would
solve the certification problem too
yes right
um
yeah we proved some other things like
for example for a worst case h
uh the optimum can be as large as
and subject to the condition that the
sum of the squares of the a's is one for
worst case h the optimum can be as large
as n
and we prove a result that's like very
analogous to character worth if you know
what that is for mexico that if i give
you an h where the optimum is epsilon n
then you can
find a solution even explicitly and
certify it a value
epsilon over log of epsilon times 10.
so if it's like kind of like a an h that
has like an unusually large optimum you
can find like a very pretty good
solution
um
but the random ones don't have an
unusually large optimum
i can also have that like
there's something even formal here like
with degree four
anti-commuting polynomials you can
simulate degree two commuting
polynomials so it's like formally like
sort of strictly harder than like
optimizing a degree two polynomial over
the movement
actually that your character worked and
i can say that you might have to lose
log factors a constant may not be enough
i'm very interested to know if there's
like a like a
the high-end trade-off like you have in
max that like if you have a before
polynomial whose optimum is like
one minus epsilon times the
absolute upper bound
you know is there an efficient argument
that gets you one minus epsilon prime
times the absolute maximum or epsilon
prime goes to zero with epsilon would
that be interesting for physics class
chemistry
yeah
i don't know if
the the it seems i don't have like
theorems here but it seems
that um
the polynomials which are close to
the maximum
look like squares of degree two things
or maybe like a sum of a small number of
squares of degree two things
um and maybe that's why you can hope to
do something with them and how many
theorems do that affect i'm not sure if
those are interesting in chemistry or
not
maybe
and it's the simulation of two commuting
variables you just referred to because
products of paris views commute with
each other like pairs of fermions or
bosons yeah like if you have like you
know these anti-commuting indeterminants
chi 1 through pi n you're just like
let's okay i'll use a a latin letter
like let y ones be
i the square root of one times chi 1 pi
2
y 2 v i times chi 3 chi 4
plus y 3 v i times
pi 5 pi 6
and then the y's you can just easily
check the y's have the property that
they're self-a joint and they square to
the identity
and they commute
and therefore you're like in the same
algebra as the algebra of like plus
minus ones and you can do some
elementary things to check that like
it's like a perfect simulation
there's only one assignment that's not
happening in the boolean team well
actually it is there is like only one
assignment you have to worry about for
the boolean queue it's the assignment
where to like you're trying to give
matrices to chi 1 k 2 up to pi n
these are going to be 2 to the n
dimensional matrices
and they're going to be diagonal
matrices and they're going to have all
pluses and minuses on the diagonals
such that
um
uh for every you know position like you
have all two to the n binary strings
here
you basically take all two dna binary
strings which is like an assignment of
like a one-dimensional matrix to each
chi i but then you stack them like lock
diagonally into like some giant two to
the n-dimensional matrices
and indeed like
when you plug these in to your
polynomial
you'll get two to the n eigenvalues and
those eigenvalues will be like all the
to the end assignment values all the
evaluations yeah so you're doing all the
evaluations
exactly so it's actually
the same yeah it's literally the same
problem
this is also the same as like saying
another way to say that is that like all
these these assignments look like a
bunch of eyes
and then a z and then a bunch of eyes
where you have like the z in like one of
n different positions
oh such a great question thank you
stephen oh man the question was as the
degree increases so we were looking at
degree 4
syk you can look at degree
q they call it q
syk
which is just like random
degree
q
polynomial
random meaning like gaussian
coefficients you always normalize it so
the expected sum of squares is one
and if you do the physics heuristic
you can repeat it but like the bigger q
is like the more
likely two random indeterminants like
overlap and so it's kind of like
these monomials um
commute with like lower probability
and
it
goes like
uh
it depends first of all whether q is
even or odd if q is odd
then you do this computation and it
looks like a wrong marker
so for odd q
uh the optimum should be order one we
don't know how to prove that
um
as q gets larger and larger it stays
looking like a gaussian let's say six to
even q for a second as q gets larger and
larger it stays looking like a gaussian
until q is proportional to square root n
um for birthday paradox reasons that's
the point which two random monomials of
a constant chance of having some overlap
and then uh
the answer starts to change
and you get an explicit distribution of
compact support
uh called the q hermite polynomial that
q is not the same as this q it's the
q of like combinatorialist like deformed
q models of things
um but some explicit thing actually with
compact support so it's optimum should
be order one
and then as cube tends towards and it
tends towards the semicircle law
so the physicists are also quite excited
that like there's a phase transition at
like square root m for like what syk
looks like whereas we're quite used
unused to like studying you know random
degree root then you know
yeah are these two things you just
mentioned related to uh like testing the
good or some just some other sequence
that that's done ah
yeah
they have been studied for example by
like three probabilists like roland
spiker has a paper where he's studying
these distributions it's like a one
family parameter of
probability distributions you can write
down the pdf it's like sort of annoying
but it has a property if you vary the
parameter to one limit it becomes a
semicircle law if you vary the parameter
to the other limit it becomes a gaussian
and like outside these two limits it's
some you know strange function of
compact support
and there's like something like
alternate odd version of that with like
the same properties but like instead of
going to gaussian it goes to rotten
marker
so does it fairly matter when q is
larger than movement
yeah the parity always matters i'm
pretty sure
yeah i think it's like q goes to like
from constant up to m through the odds
if i remember it correctly like it stays
like a wrong marker until root n
oh and then
yeah maybe not i think then it changes
to
this explicit distribution and then it
changes the semicircle i have to check
actually i can't remember
okay thank you very much
so let's make it